[Music]
when you face an uncomfortable situation
you might choose to run and hide but
wouldn't it be easier if you could
suddenly blend into your surroundings
in what ways could you camouflage your
body
how would your skin need to be different
and how would this ability change the
way you interact with the world
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you had camouflaged skin
many animals can camouflage or disguise
their appearance whether it's a defense
mechanism to avoid predators or an
ability that helps them hunt prey they
use different camouflage strategies
some animals perform this magic trick
with the help of biochromes or pigments
that reflect or absorb all the visible
wavelengths of light
in other creatures the physical
structure of their skin scales or hair
acts like a prism scattering or
refracting the light around them
so if you could change into any color
would you
hey
where'd you go
which method of camouflage would work
best for you
well let's look at some of the animal
kingdom's most skilled masters of
disguise
maybe the most famous camouflager would
be the chameleon
it changes colors when it feels afraid
aggressive or tries to attract a mate
if you had a chameleon's abilities
you could change from green to blue to
bright orange in seconds
your skin would need to have
crystal-like cells called erytophores
that refract light
they would compress or expand based on
your emotions and change your coloring
if you felt angry or passionate you'd
turn bright red
when you feel relaxed you might be a
darker shade of blue so no one bothers
you
or you could show off every color in
your palette to impress your latest
crush
okay now let's track down an arctic fox
in the warmer months its brown coat
allows it to blend into the greens and
browns of its environment
but in winter its fur turns white to
blend in with the endless snowy tundra
this protects the arctic fox from
predators and the prey at stocks
if your hair color naturally changed
each season
you probably wouldn't need it to survive
but it could be an excuse to spend
summers at the beach as a blonde or
embrace the winter's darkness with jet
black hair
now if you wanted to disappear
the best strategy would come from
flounders
huh
these fish change their color to match
their surroundings using their vision
and skin cells
as they move through different
environments their retinas recognize
different colors they transmit that
information to their skin cells which
adjust their colors
if you felt threatened or wanted to
avoid an old flame walking nearby
you could use this strategy
people would have a tough time spotting
you if you looked like a brick building
or a parked car
but if they did see you changing colors
it would probably make the situation
even more awkward
maybe you'd be better off turning bright
golden orange like the golden tortoise
beetle
that would give the impression that
you're poisonous and people should avoid
you
and if everyone else suddenly had
camouflaged skin
it would change how everyone interacted
people already expressed themselves with
clothing tattoos and hairstyles
now they'd be able to change their style
or vibe very quickly
people with eye-catching skin would show
they're open to new connections and
people who didn't want to be bothered
would simply disappear before your eyes
but this would present a threatening
possibility too
military groups would camouflage much
more efficiently without needing
clothing or paints
there could be spies hiding in plain
sight and gathering all kinds of
information about you
so you'd have to stay even more alert
and keep your eyes peeled
but at least they wouldn't be able to
make themselves completely invisible
or
could they
well
that's a story
for another
what if
[Music]
you